pierre richard on va rester dans le
monologue pas faire une interview
monologue
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
dieu que je suis moche pendant très
longtemps je me suis pas aimé ah ouais
ouais après j'ai commencé à m'aimer avec
la barbe et la géo toulouse il a couru
pour un film mais et donc je continue à
ne plus aimer du tout on savait pas mal
on me l'a dit après oui
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
venez sur un plateau de télé
si je veux vraiment une frange il merde
je suis pas à l'aise ah oui là ça va
vous êtes gentils avec vous on peut être
que gentil que celui que je fasse des
dons en général je les refuse ouais
c'est vrai on voit pas souvent je crois
que c'est même la première fois que vous
venez ici ben c'était vraiment pour lui
c'est gentil merci pour lui
j'ai dit je serai grand
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
vous levez le matin
je crois que je pense tout de suite à
manger oui je me lève avec la fin
et je me couche avec la soif mais
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous vous
regardez dans un miroir ça ressemble un
peu à ma première question c'est vrai
oui ça
je me suis dit c'est la première
question
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
seul chez vous le soir devant un miroir
ou pas non c'est important pas de miroir
à vrai dire je suis pas souvent sur le
soir vous pouvez pas être seul j'ai du
mal à être seul et or général chez avec
une femme quand même et donc si elle est
pas là je sors ah oui on dirait qu'il ya
bien un moment où je rentre oui
on en revient à votre question 18 ans
l'âge du rien puisque je suis mort de
fatigue et je dors fou qu'est ce que
vous dites quand vous voyez votre
parcours
c'est
ce sont des sentiments mélangés
mais comme je suis quand même quelqu'un
ou très reconnaissant dans la vie je me
dis que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance que
je suis un privilégié et que
j'aime tellement la vie j'aimerais bien
la recommencer le double
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
énervé
quand je suis énervé je dis d'aidé
j'ai dit des gros mots aux brésiliens et
pour ta réparions déroule à aller
d'accord qu'est ce que vous dites quand
vous avez envie d'abandonner ce métier
j'ai jamais eu environ à ce métier
jamais jamais le métier ne m'aura
jusqu'à la mort qu'est ce que vous dites
quand vous regarder le journal télévisé
mon dieu ouais qu'est ce que vous dites
quand vous ne recevez pas de scénario
pas de nouvelle bonne nouvelle
réflexe le paresseux
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
voyez une actrice qui veut coucher avec
vous
qu'est ce que je vous dis je dis oui
oui enfin bon
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez pas confiance en vous
la seule chose que je me dis
c'est c'est un souvenir de mon grand
père sur son lit de mort qui m'a dit tu
réussiras non j'ai pas confiance en moi
je me suis souvenu de ça et je crois
qu'il m'a il a porté cet ultime phrase
de cette son existence m'a toujours
conforté dans et d'un optimisme
un
caractérisée sur sûrement devenir ouais
qu'est ce que vous dites quand on vous
dit que vous n'êtes pas drôle
ça m'énerve
mais je reconnais à à quiconque de
trouver drôle ouais je ne dirais pas est
un con
même si je le pense un peu des fois
mais en tout cas je vous dirai pas
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez rien à vous dire
que je ferme les corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux